State takes Paw Patrol to a whole new
level as one pup helps seize millions of
dollars in drugs last week Quinn is a
two-year-old golden lab that spends his
time as a narcotic sniffing dog for the
Burien Police Department the former
Purina Puppy Chow model came in at the
tail end of a year-long investigation
into a massive drug cartel operation
police estimate that they've seized 10
million dollars in drugs from their
operation and Quinn sniffed out almost a
third of it including crystal meth
Fentanyl and black tar heroin six people
were recently arrested in connection to
the operation and a King County Judge
found probable cause for drug possession
with intent to deliver prosecutors are
expected to press charges this week
Brian you've got a doberman at home with
some unique training how does a pooch go
from model to officer yeah so my dog as
training was called then shitson
training or it's German protection
training but this is detection work and
this is amazing I've tried to teach my
dog this but it's very difficult so dogs
can especially golden labs like we're
seeing here are a phenomenal at
detecting substances they're even able
to when someone's about to have a stroke
but what they do is they take the
specific substance whether it be
marijuana heroin fentanyl anything and
in small amounts and they hide it in
different areas for the dog to then
detect then a dog shows a certain
response either they sit I think this
dog jumped on the table or laid down
whatever that signal is it's up to the
trainer to be able to identify that and
then spot the drugs this dog did an
amazing job this is not easy I had to
cross-examine Canine officers about
their training and these dogs are heroes
on all fronts I thought you were I had
to cross-examine the dogs
yeah he kept pleading the fifth yeah
Terry this is a dog definitely earned
some doggy treats right what can you
tell us about the use of canines in law
enforcement well you know in all
seriousness these dogs are very
important they really have been using
dogs for patrol since the Middle Ages
and there are two types that you get you
get those like Brian was talking about
for detection and most of those are labs
and you also get them for Patrol and a
lot of those dogs are German Shepherds
so they have to be trained and they have
to make sure there's no hesitation when
they have their training and then
they're selected to actually go on the
job they usually work about six to nine
years and they take their jobs very
seriously and of course they are
rewarded for what they do but when
they're out in the field and they're
actually smelling things and sniffing
things out it really helps law
enforcement because if a officer is at a
car and the dog is smelling the car and
there's some drugs in there they have
reasonable cause to go and investigate
inside the car and you know it's the
same thing at the airport so they're
very helpful very helpful and then they
retire they open up a pi agency it's a
whole world of dogs that nobody knows
about Brian Terry thanks so much
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on Long crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss Justice in
America
[Music]